last day of the workshop on multi-agent
rl and uh bandit learning so to start us
off today we're really excited to have
giannis panagios from uc irvine joining
us and he's going to be telling us about
his work on uh yeah convergence of
multi-agent policy gradient in markov
games so i'll let yanis take it away
uh thank you for the introduction um i
wish i was there but
due to teaching duties i have to give
this talk remotely
so this is a joint work with stefano
leonardos
who is a
postdoc of georgios and
he's going to join king's college will
government who was my student and he
will join stanford as a phd and of
course georgios
so
we are going to talk about uh
policy grading methods and
in
in mark of potential games and
we are going to talk about positive
results along these lines
so
uh what are market agent systems so
you know there is no need for
introduction you can think of it as
decentralized systems where you have
like a lot of individuals these
individuals might cooperate or compete
with each other
there is a rationality
and of course you need to use some
you need to use optimization in some
distributed way and there are many like
applications
like self-driving cars auctions robotics
and so on so forth so
what is the goal the goal is typically
to have to make predictions about the
evolution of such systems okay
so yeah the introduction is very is very
brief because by now of course
there have been many talks on on the
area so let me go through the formal
framework
so in in the multi-agent settings
effectively
uh multi-generating enforcement learning
um
the the
the framework is very similar to the
single agent case so you have n agents
okay you have a finite state space
now you have a joint action space which
is like
the cartesian product of the action
space of the action space of each agent
okay you have also a transition
probability model so given the actions
of all the players of all the agents and
the the state they are
uh there is a probability to transition
to some other state s prime okay each
agent is associated with a reward
function
that depends on the state and the joint
action of all players okay
which is a finite number let's say
between 0 and 1 and for infinite horizon
markov
processes
um
we use a discounted factor gamma uh if
it is finite horizon we may assume that
gamma is equal to one
and
we care about uh a solution concept that
we call nas policy or nass equilibrium
uh this is debatable there might be
other resolution concepts like uh course
correlate equilibria but please note
that there is no notion of uh optimality
as opposed to the singly agent because
now every agent has his own value his
own reward so every agent wants to
maximize his own uh
value function so
sometimes you can imagine that it's
impossible that everybody can maximize
simultaneously their values
so we care about the nas policies um so
what is a nas policy
effectively you can think of it as a
a double of policies so that if you
freeze
n minus one agents
effectively uh the remaining agent
appears best response so please
his optimal uh
it plays a policy that gives him the
optimal value
if you have frozen the rest of the
agents and this is true for all the
agents okay
so that's the definition of a nas policy
and this is like um
the same notion effectively as a nas
equilibrium
in normal form games
and
more importantly nas policies always
exist
this is uh
something that is really important
otherwise this notion wouldn't make a
lot of sense you know if if it if there
was no universality of the notion
and uh yeah if you freeze all the agents
but one effectively uh you define a
single agent mdp okay so
you can think of it as uh
every agent plays best response
if you fix the rest of the agents so
this is the solution concept we are
going to
uh
examine uh today
uh
and let me start by giving an example of
a two agent
zero sum uh
markov game so
you have like two states uh the state
has zero and test one and you can think
like that the transition model says with
probability p
you jump from state 0 to state 1 and
with probability q you jump from state 1
to state 0
at state 0 the two agents play
rock paper scissors and at state 1 they
play like matching pennies
so this is what we call a two-player
stochastic uh
zero-sum game
so
this these settings are more or less
well understood
by this time
effectively someplace showed that this
uh to play zero some games stochastic
where zero some games have have always a
value
in particular
uh you can solve the min max
theorem so min max equals max mean
uh
note that this does not carry over from
von neumann because uh you don't have
convexity and concavity uh on the value
functions so
this this is the a huge challenge
when you have uh
rl settings
you don't have a normal form game so
your your value function is not
linear or convex with respect to your
variables for each player okay
so
this was like one of the
uh let's say main ingredients uh
that was used in the skylake center
to show that
if you run like a
two-time scale uh policy gradient
effectively you can recover
uh nas policy in uh two players zero sum
games okay
and i would like to note that in general
finding
a nas policy in my data settings is hard
it's computationally hard and this is
trivial from
the results we know in complexity theory
for computing nas equilibria
all the negative results carry over to
the multi-agent settings okay
uh
i would like to note that uh
you know more recently there were like a
couple of papers that showed even for
weaker notions of
of
equilibrium
concept even in like course corrugated
even in this case uh computing of course
correlated equilibrium under like some
assumptions stationarity and markovian
policies it is hard so in general the
problem is computationally hard
[Music]
so
nevertheless the there are like methods
like policy grading that is commonly
used and is very successful
so
what is policy grading effectively you
can think that uh policy granting is
like gradient descent gradient ascent on
the on the value function okay
so effectively if you're ungrading
ascend on the value function and um
and you do some sort of projection in
the simplex you
you have you have a candidate algorithm
that might perform well and by well i
mean of course it will not run
in polynomial time in the description of
the
of the process but hopefully
it will run
it will give an answer in in a good
amount of time and uh typically um how
we parameterize the value function well
we we use like the direct what we call
the direct parameterization where
effectively
every every number is associated to a
variable so by every number i mean
um every policy for every player uh you
know the probability to play some
particular action given the state uh
this is associated with to one variable
so effectively you have like points in
the simplex and this is how you
parameterize your value function and
then you run policy gradient on on on
these values
on the value function so for single
agent cases uh
there was uh
the paper by agrawal uh
from 2020 and they showed that you know
if you run policy gradient
after one over epsilon square iteration
units an epsilon optimal policy so this
is true for single agent cases
and
this was effectively
generalized in
under some uh other assumptions like you
have two times scale etc was generalized
for two player zero sum games um
so in in in the sky accident paper
um and
you know i mean when when i first came
across these two papers uh the the the
question that arise to me was
could this police grinding works for
single agent and two eurozones to host
games does it work for more general
settings okay so can we have any
guarantees for more than two players
that was
the the question that i i wanted to
address and
this is what i'm going to address in
this talk basically
i want to define like classes of
stochastic games where effectively
policy gradient ascent gives guarantees
about convergence to
our solution concept which is the nas
policies
so this is going to be the talk
the the
the talk for today
uh and the the notion of uh the class of
games that i'm going to define are
called like a mark of potential games
so mark of potential games effectively
is a notion that is uh
the generalization of potential games
that you have in classic game theory
so what is a mark of potential game
where effectively
it's a mark of decision
with mighty in my agent setting so many
agents
and
you assume that there exists an energy
function called potential okay this is
like a state dependent function
so that
if any of the players so say that the
every player uses some
policy pie i
if
one player deviates from his policy the
difference in this energy function is
captured by the difference
in
his value function so and this is true
for for all possible items and all
possible deviations
so this is like exactly um
in in if if the game goes stated as this
exactly what the potential
potential function potential game is in
normal phone games
well
this notion is kind of important
in in classic game theory because it
captures routing games uh
it's a class of games that
we we know that they always have pure
nas uh they consider easier than um
you know two-player general some games
and so on and so forth and
what is cool about this class is that we
can also show that
deterministic nash policies always exist
by deterministic i mean that
if if an agent is at a particular state
it takes an action with probability one
yes quick question is your um action
space here uh continuous uh as in like
uh or no no it's a defining it's a
finite action space and are the previous
results also for finite action space yes
what i have mentioned right now is for
the two papers are for action finite
action space okay and would this
definition hold for uh compact like uh
continuous action spaces or would you
need to modify this you think uh yeah i
mean you can
uh that's a good question so for for
actions uh yeah i mean
it goes over
but
but only the action space can be
continuous okay
so yeah the the definition can carry
over sure okay awesome cool i'm not sure
i'm not sure if the results carry over
uh it's not clear to me but the
definition yeah
so okay
thanks
sure um so
what is cool about this notion is that
the deterministic uh
uh nas police always exist and by
deterministic i mean that
the particular state
you play an action with probability one
so it's not the distribution of their
actions it's just a deterministic choice
and uh
what is uh
kind of surprising and uh i'll show you
examples in a moment is that when you
have this
mark of potential games if you if if i
just give you you know the graph and the
and the transition model it's not clear
whether
it is an mpg or not so characterizing
mpgs is not an easy task of course if i
give you the the function phi or if i
give you the values of the players
then you can check
whether or not it is a potential game
but if i just give you
the
the transition model it's it's not easy
to
come up with um
to to to understand if it is a potential
game or not
so let's see some examples of uh
of potential games so here is an example
of a of an mpg
uh
so this this mpg here is a is a is a two
player uh game you have six states okay
so in the first state test zero people
play uh matching pennies okay
depending on the choice so if if both
players play heads you you jump to state
this one if if players play tails they
jump here if one plays head and the
other plays tails you jump here and
if if the first player plays tails in
the second head you jump here
and then deterministically
you go to state s1
in which in state s1 with probability p0
you go back to zero and with probability
one minus p zero you remain at s1
in s1 you play
a potential game so this is a two player
potential game
um
so in these four states here what what
you do is uh
effectively you play
it's like a dummy game so
you have only one strategy and you play
you are guaranteed to get these payoffs
these rewards
so it turns out that
this particular game is mp is an mpg so
there is a function phi that
captures the deviation of the players
but note that what is a kind of cool
is that at status 0
the game is a zero-sum game
so all i want to say from this example
is that you might have states where
the game the associated game to that
state is a is a sum game but overall
the whole uh rl process is uh
is an mpg
so yeah you can have some games that are
zero sum okay so this setting the mark
of potential games effectively seem to
capture
cases like that
here is another example of a game that
is not
an mpg
probably
but
you we we call it an almost mpg or an
ordinal
mpg so how it works you have like again
two players two states
um if you are at state zero
if both players play uh plus one they
remain at state zero if they play
anything else they jump to state one
so at state zero these are like uh the
values this is the payoff matrix and at
stay one uh state one they both get
value zero okay
uh it turns out that there is no uh
value function that captures the
deviations
but this is an ordinal mpg so what is an
ordinal mpg let's go back to the
definition
so
here the equality is violated but what
it matters is that the left-hand side
has the same value as the has the same
sign as the right-hand side so in
particular if the left-hand side is
positive then the right-hand side is
positive if the left hand side is
negative then the right hand side is
negative
if if such a case works without equality
then we call it an ordinal npg and the
results we are going to see in a moment
under some weak assumptions they carry
over for ordinary mpgs as well
uh
unfortunately uh
what is also true is that if you have
like a
setting where every sub game is a
potential game this does not guarantee
that the whole mdp is a mark of
potential game and here is an easy
example again two players two states
uh state zero um
the first player gets always a two the
second player gets always a zero this is
reversed at state one and
the transitions happen like this
so player a and player b they choose
something if the xor is zero you made
that state zero if the xor is one you
jump to s1
and the same is there if if the xor is
zero you remain at state one otherwise
you jump to state zero
so this you know every state effectively
is a dummy game right so it's a constant
game you always get
uh two and the other player gets zero or
the opposite
so they are
trivially potential games
with a function
with a constant function as a potential
nevertheless this this process simulates
effectively matching pens
so
what what is the take away message from
this
game is that transitions can create
competition
most importantly you can show that this
is not a potential game and you can show
that there are no deterministic nas
policies um
so yeah it's not about the the sub game
it's sub game it's also about the
transitions if the transitions depend on
the choice of the actions of the players
then you can have anything you you can
imagine okay so this is the takeaway
message from this guy
so what is our main results effectively
our main results are the following
suppose that the players
they play uh
they run policy gradient independently
meaning
that i just
see my value function and i update
according to my value function okay and
this is true for every player
what it can be shown is that after one
over epsilon square iterations you can
reach an epsilon as policy okay for a
mark of potential games
uh
what i want to say is that
this one over epsilon square
has a dependence on
its depends linearly also on the state
space
and the depends linearly
uh on the sum of the action of the
cardinalities of the actions of spaces
of the agents so one one might say okay
since this is like you have an
underlying function what you can do is
you can define a
one agent game you know define a meta
player that effectively has as a value
function the potential and try to
solve the single agent case well this is
true and it will give you uh also and
one over epsilon square
running time but the dependence
on the action space is different so you
have a cartesian product
for the join action space nevertheless
in our setting we assume that every
player effectively updates independently
so
the running time depends linearly on the
sum of the cardinalities of the action
spaces and not at the product okay
and this is kind of crucial because uh
you know one one of the main obstacles
in multi-general is the huge action
uh and this result is uh under the
assumption that we have full information
about the value function this might not
be
realistic so we also have a finite
samples okay
so we can show the same result if the
agents
update independently using stochastic
policy gradient method
and the rates
change a bit from one over epsilon
square it's one over epsilon to the six
same dependence on the state in action
space okay
nevertheless i'll talk about it a bit
later but you cannot use
the direct parameterization the direct
parameterization due to some
difficulties you need to to change your
parameterization and last but not least
i want to say that you know this the
deterministic result effectively matches
the single agent
case
so let me take talk a bit about the
proof for the deterministic case and
also for the stochastic
um
the the first observation that is uh
true also for normal form games is that
if you take uh
the partial derivative of
the energy function the potential
function with respect to some variable
uh let's say that is associated to
player i
uh this is equal to if you take the the
partial derivative of
that player's value function with
respect to the same variable so
effectively all i'm saying is that the
gradient of phi is effectively the
concatenation of the gradients of the
value functions
so what this enable us to do
effectively
uh we can run
policy gradient on on file even if we
don't know
phi we know its existence only
as long as we know v
v i um we can run policy gradient uh or
effectively its gradient ascent on
function phi okay and this is true
because uh of this key lemma
so we don't know phi but we know v i's
so we can run gradient policy gradient
on v i's but this coincides with the
gradient as n on phi
uh the the second key lemma that is also
very important is that you need to
connect um
the stationary points of phi
the first order stationary points of i
with uh
with um um the nas policies
again our goal is to to find nash
policies to convert sunas policies so
when you run first order methods you are
guaranteed to convert to first order
stationarity
so somehow we need to relate the two
so it turns out that stationary points
for phi are exactly nash policies okay
uh so this is this was true in
aggravated
foster and gold of its paper and and
they they they use this uh technical
lemma that is uh this property this very
nice property that is called gradient
domination
so gradient domination property is like
a weaker notion of pl condition okay
which what does it say effectively if
you have a function f
okay and you see f at optimality minus
the value of the function f at some
arbitrary point x
this difference is of the order of
g of x where z is some notion of first
order
stationarity so in particular you can
think that the right hand side is the
norm of the gradient
if the right hand side is the norm of
the gradient
stationarity implies optimality okay
because
if the gradient is zero it means that
the
at the x naught let's say it means that
f of x naught is equal to f of x star
so gradient domination effectively says
that stationarity implies optimality
okay
uh
and this is true here for nash policies
so stationarity for mighty agent implies
nas policies
and uh
of course we we don't compute exactly
the nas policies so we approximate so
the key lemma to
better carry over for approximations as
well so it is true that approximate
stationary points or four phi are also
st approximate nas policies
okay
so
without further ado
then we use a very standard uh result
that if you run gradient ascent or
gradient descent i have in this slide
you are guaranteed to convert
stationarity after one of the epsilon
squares steps as you guys your function
is uh smooth so it has ellipses gradient
and
this this is trivially true because of
this descent lemma you can show that if
you have a function f that is a
function f that is uh
smooth
then if you run the step of gradient
descent
your
value always decreases okay so
if you do that like for for ti turrets
and you assume that you haven't reached
stationarity
you can read some sort of contradiction
so effectively if your function is
smooth uh is lower bounded
then after one over epsilon square steps
you are guaranteed to reach an epsilon
stationary point and by absolute
stationary i mean that the the norm of
the gradient is at most epsilon okay so
this is very very well known and uh by
now
follicular result
so combining this
with the previous two kilometers you
trivially follows the result for the
deterministic
case okay
well
trivial is not
the correct term because you need to
show also
the smoothness of phi okay
so you need to show that phi is leaves
its gradient
but we don't know phi so
we need to work with
v i's so you need to show that
the gradient of v i is
ellipsis okay
and
we can show that where
the ellipse is constant depends on the
number of agents the number of actions
and the discounted factor gamma okay
so
also i'm going to talk about the
stochastic case for the stochastic case
you need
something that is called an unbiased
estimator of the gradient and also you
need
that
the the gradient is uh
the the estimator result has also
bounded variance
so
it turns out that the estimator that was
provided by um
the scaliaques goal of the foster and
golovitz in uh in their paper
effectively is an unbiased estimator so
what is this
estimator basically at every iterate
okay what you do
is uh
you take an epoch well
what you you assume that gamma is the
probability now that your process
terminates
so and what you do is
at every state you take a sample a
sample trajectory under the
the interpretation that gamma is the
probability uh basically the probability
to keep going and one minus gamma the
probability to terminate the process
and you you take this uh
this uh estimator where this term is
just the sum of the rewards of the
sample trajectory okay
and
it turns out that
the expectation of this term gives you
exactly the value the the gradient
for uh the value functions
so it turns out that
this is a what we call an unbiased
estimator
but this does not guarantee convergence
for stochastic settings and the reason
is this imagine if that you have
a lot of noise in your estimator
effectively
you can think that you can go anywhere
so
unbiased estimator doesn't give much you
need also that the variance of this
estimator is is bounded
nevertheless
also
in the acetal paper they showed that the
variance is uh unbounded okay
now
if if the variance is unbounded what you
can do is uh basically change your
parameterization
as long as you change your
parameterization and with appropriate
choice of the parameters
you can show um
that the variance becomes bounded so
what is the parameterization we use
so what is called alpha grady
parametrization basically
the interpretation of alpha grid is this
uh with high probability
uh i i play the policy i have and with
some small probability i play uniform uh
distribution over actions so effectively
the greedy parameterization has also an
exploration term here okay
and having this exploration term here
effectively what it does it pushes you
away from the boundary
and the boundary of the simplex is what
makes
the variance of the estimator unbounded
so effectively under this
parameterization
uh you can have like a
unbounded uh bounded variants of this
estimator
nevertheless
since uh
you have this uh
exploration uh
term
it means that you you you will not find
an exact nas policy right so this is an
extra error you need to accumulate when
you do the approximation
so
basically it turns out that if you
choose the the greedy parameterization
to be
uh the square of the step size of your
process you are guaranteed to give
an epsilon approximate nas policy uh
so yeah after one over epsilon to the
six iterations uh you are guaranteed to
convert to a nas policy and uh the
difference between one over epsilon
square from of the deterministic and one
over epsilon to the sixth of the
stochastic is due to this uh term
exploration term we have here in the
greedy parametrization to avoid the
unboundedness of the variance
so
this these results these positive
results are about
nas policies in mark of potential games
so we have stronger notions okay
but we have like uh so nash policies is
a very strong notion but we can do it
only for uh restricted uh settings like
mark of potential games
uh it turns out that like um
six months ago there were like two three
papers that
almost concurrent
same same month
that they talked about uh
effectively general some games but the
notion the solution concept they care
about is not math policy is course
correlated
or correlated equilibria okay
so there was there is a paper also
um by zanga tal that they have
almost identically result to ours
the stochastic case
was a subsequent work but uh in their
case
they don't use the same estimator as we
do they they use
a more uh
i would say
uh natural estimator that they also
guaranteed to show that is
unbiased and
the results carry over so they match
the running time uh
also there is a paper by song ital
that
they propose an algorithm that is not
like uh
the agents do not
update independently so you allow only
one agent to update at a time okay so
think that
in our case all the agents update
simultaneously okay if you assume that
one agent updates at the time
they have a
one over epsilon cube
convergence
guaranteed for the stochastic case which
is like a
big improvement of the one over epsilon
to the six we have
and but it's more centralized okay
and uh even more recently like a couple
of months ago there was uh there is this
paper by dinghy
well they focus also on mark of
potential games and
they effectively circumvent the gradient
domination property they do some
improved analysis
so they have improved rates
and also they do a function
approximation uh for the setting of uh
mark of potential games so this is one
of the first
results about function approximation for
multi-gen settings though the result is
only for linear functions and
yeah i mean technically i guess it will
be more challenging if we have
non-linearities
[Music]
so
this
these are these are like uh
some interesting works
and
let me talk a bit about future
directions for the remaining three
minutes
so
right now what i talked about is
policy grading and convergence to
um nas policies uh for uh marco
potential games nevertheless i didn't
talk about
the properties of the nas policies in
particular we know that in markov
potential games you always have
deterministic nas policies okay
is there is there a way to show that
if you let's say start at random from
some policy you are guaranteed to
actually converts to deterministic
policies or you you are guaranteed to
converge with high probability or with
probability one you know under uh
uh maybe using these techniques from
dynamical systems and so on so forth
so yeah can we talk about deterministic
nas policies
one other
thing that i want to talk about and i
think this is a really really
interesting future work is the following
so
right now
instead people do not actually use
only policy grading methods they use
something else that's called natural
policy grading so in natural policy
grading what is really happening is that
you
avoid a term that is called the mismatch
coefficient um in the running time and
this is true for a single agent settings
okay
moreover natural policy gradient is a
method that is uh
really important because
you have
something that is called soft max
parameterization
and effectively natural policy grading
is used also to do neural policy grading
which is a way to improve a function
to do function approximation
so understanding the rate of convergence
of natural policy gradle and for
multi-agent settings is really is really
a cool
it's really a uh
future direction right now what we know
is this uh
along with the fox mcclear and the
overman we showed that
in potential games mark of potential
game natural policy gradient converges
has last title convergence nash policies
so in the limit you reach a nice policy
but
we couldn't prove rates okay
so
then they have a paper that they prove
rates but they have some very strong
assumptions
and these assumptions uh make the
the setting very restrictive
even more recently uh like two weeks ago
or even less there is a paper that talks
about natural policy grading but you
have
entropy regularization
in these settings
for normal form games
they guaranteed to show rates of
convergence and
yeah for me uh it would be really
interesting to show rates of convergence
for natural policy grading for
multi-agent settings
avoiding this mismatch coefficient okay
and
yeah this is a very interesting future
direction
uh but even even i i guess more
conceptually interesting is to go beyond
competition or cooperation right now
most of the results we have seen
for nas policies at least
they talk about either zero-sum games or
potential games
also i want you to note that trivially
if you have full cooperation this is a
mark of potential game
with uh so if everybody gets the same
reward
then the potential is just the value of
all the players so mark of potential
games it trivially capture full
cooperation
so what happens in settings where you
have like both
competition and comparison in particular
imagine settings where you have two
things that they compete with each other
okay
effectively what is happening is that
players inside one team they cooperate
with each other okay but
on the other hand
players uh of opposite teams they
compete with each other so these type of
settings they seem to be easier than
general some games but nevertheless are
harder than zero sum and potential games
so
yeah we have some partial results
along these lines but this is also very
interesting future direction
especially because of all the negative
results computationally uh hardness
results that have been shown uh recently
uh you know one question would be
what can we prove okay
what positive results can we prove and
uh yeah with this
i guess i'm done thank you so much
all right thanks a lot uh let's see do
we have any questions in the audience
here
oh yeah i didn't
hi so
looking back at shapley's and monday's
papers on potential games there they
propose an algorithm that converges in
finite time uh
which kind of like sounds like
coordinate ascent
on the potential function of the game so
i was wondering if like
if you could obtain a stronger result
here that you would converge actually to
nash equilibrium in finite time in this
setting maybe considering something like
coordinate ascent which kind of sounds a
lot like
a lot like the algorithm that actually
shapley considers in that paper
like it feels like there should be
stronger result that holds here in
potential games that
we don't get here right now
right so
the i think the best way we can hope for
is one over epsilon
so this is like the rate that you can
achieve uh
uh
when you run for single agent okay
and uh
i i think that uh you you probably are
right so so
i i forgot to mention one future
direction also is to have some
accelerated method uh
i'm not sure if you use coordinate
descent you can get better than one over
epsilon square
my feeling is that uh
um
it might be it might be the same uh
but i guess i'm not concerned by like
the speed of convergence as much as like
the actual convergence solution because
like sharply converges to an exact nash
equilibrium i see i see uh
you can
right so
yeah
i'll tell you so if it is so you are
talking about exact so that's your
that's your problem right yeah yeah yeah
exactly exactly
so
uh
you in polynomial time and by polynomial
time i mean like uh in the description
of the game you cannot guaranteed uh
convergence so
uh
fast conversion so if you want to talk
only about convergence uh
then the best the easiest thing you can
do okay
is uh take all possible so i told you
that the deterministic policies always
exist right
so if you don't care about the rates of
convergence
uh what you can do is just enumerate all
possible uh
pure uh
deterministic policies
and you are guaranteed that one of them
will be a nas policy and you can find it
exactly
uh i think i think what is really
important is to do it fast and also do
it in a decentralized way so that's
that's the point of uh of of these
methods if you really want to talk about
only about exactness the the easiest way
is to just enumerate all possible uh
deterministic policies and find uh
find the one that you know is a nas
policy but that doesn't sound like how
shapley does gets finite time
convergence in his paper like he doesn't
enumerate all the actions he just has a
series of like improvements constantly
that seems like we're forcing it i mean
yeah i mean yeah but he's not guaranteed
to convert fast
he will not converge fast that's what
i'm saying okay take a lot of time so so
finite time doesn't mean doesn't mean
like fast right it might be exponential
in the description of the game uh
and this is uh there are results you
know that can show you that effectively
you need exponential time uh
unconditionally in some cases
so yeah so so
you can
of course yeah you can do that but you
are not guaranteed to have a
decentralized way and you are not
guaranteed to do it in a fast way
so this algorithm here guarantees that
you know if epsilon is 0.01 you can do
it after
10 000 iterations cool and i have
another question which is just like a
preliminary question
um you said that the min max theorem
doesn't it's not guaranteed to hold in
zero sum games because in general the
value function is not comics concave but
the sequence of you know the sum of the
scan of comics concave function is
comics concave once again but the reason
that we need
uh like the proof of existence of
optimum policy in zero sum
uh games is because we want to prove
that it's independent of initial state
distributions the reason why i'm asking
that is because you haven't
told i have you told us if your value
function is guaranteed to be i guess
maybe you don't need convexity here okay
so the value function no no so the value
function is not convex that's what i'm
saying uh
and but for zero some stochastic games
exactly showed that the game has a value
okay
so the effectively this means that the
min max so
so whoever plays first i'll tell you it
in another way so say it's a stochastic
to player game so it doesn't matter who
plays first okay you can always
guarantee to have an equilibrium
solution
this is what it means nevertheless it's
not convex or concave yeah
but there is a there is the there is a
value function sorry a value of the game
of like comics functions again
[Applause]
yeah definitely here
so i have one close-ended question and
one more open-ended question a very nice
talk by the way uh the close-ended
question is um
does
a lot of would a lot of this potentially
extend to uh settings which
can be written as a potential game
markup potential game modulo or
monotonic transformation so let's say
you had a function on the values and
that function is uh is monotone um and
you can still get potential structure uh
do you think there's scope for extending
it do you think it's easy to extend
everything here too uh so
right so
not everything uh
so if you for example the the
monotonicity that you are mentioned if
you can guarantee that there is a
constant okay
ci let's say so that's the difference
between uh
then the energy the potential
the in the deviation is equal to some
constant ci
times the difference in the value
function
then everything carries over
the problem is that
monotonicity itself does not guarantee
that the results carry over because
you might have a vanishing term that is
uh associated with let's say the
difference of the values so it might be
the case that the difference in the
potential is huge but the difference in
the values is really really tiny or the
other way around
so the
as long as when the difference in the
value functions is uh is not
too small or too large compared to the
value to the difference of the potential
values then yeah the results carry over
so only with monotonicity no the results
do not carry over uh
i mean the results yeah that makes sense
you're neutral kind of bounded slope
yeah
the rates the rates of convergence did
not carry over
yeah yeah the rates of convergence yeah
yeah that makes a lot of sense and my
more open-ended question was uh
do you think or have you thought about
easy like recipes for verifying that a
markov game is a mark of potential game
i'm curious about how you came up with
those examples so so all right that's a
good that's a great question so
uh if you know the value function is
easy okay you just take
the the partial derivative since you
check equality say that you only know
the transition model and you don't know
anything about the phi or v or the v's
uh there are there is
there is a way to characterize uh
mpgs but in terms of uh
compute computationally right if if
there is a fast way to do it or not
the answer is
no i think so and the reason is uh i
i'll give you
an easy answer so even in normal form
games right so if i give you if i give
you a setting and i don't
tell you anything about um
uh
basically i cannot tell you anything
about the game like
only only you can query about the the
values
uh it's not easy to to learn if the game
is a potential game or not so i have a
feeling that
characterizing
so
the there is a characterization by
saplay uh
in particular
but uh but this characterization is not
uh
something that you can do it fast okay
right this is not due to the derivatives
like you were mentioning i think yes so
so
the easiest way i can answer this is
that if you have the value functions
take the partial derivatives
basically and check uh and check if they
are if you have equality uh
i think uh this is the the easiest way
but if you if you have no clue about the
values it's kind of tricky
got it yeah that's a nice answer thank
you sure
i guess maybe i had one last question
um so i guess so yeah i you kind of
briefly mentioned this at the end so
like you know in the the agarwal and all
paper for the single agent case
uh you know they have this like
distribution mismatch coefficient which
is looking at kind of like the ratio
between like the density for the optimal
policy and the initial state
distribution right and then yeah you
know in the paper with like uh costas
and noah we kind of had like uh you know
like a two-player analog of this this
quantity
i guess i was wondering what the kind of
multi-player analog of this looks like
in your paper so so yeah so i'll give
you an easy answer uh
take like uh the ratio between any
policy
over the initial distribution yeah and
take the maximum of all these
uh this is this is uh this is a bound on
the mismatch coefficient
[Music]
so yeah so you in in your paper you you
take the ma the the max over uh let's
say
of where all policies but you take the
mean over the policy of uh
of the the other agent right yeah yeah
yeah you had this kind of definition so
in our case think that you take the
maximum overall joint policies
uh this is your uh
your uh
numerator in the
you know the visitation probability okay
find the maximum over all policies and
then divide it by the
initial distribution
so you need you need full support uh
first of all you need full support in uh
so you need your initial distribution to
be
of full support
for sure
yeah
it's the maximum overall joint policies
okay okay so i guess i was wondering
like if there's any hope for getting
something tighter than that in this
setting or if you have oh more um
yeah you can restrict it only to
to not spoil you know i mean
instead of the maximum overall joint
policies you might take the um
you might take the max from all the nas
policies so restrict the said to all the
nash policies okay
and uh
take like the maximum uh
um visitation probability from all of
them uh yeah and this you can define the
mismatch like this
okay interesting it's huge it's huge it
can be exponential in the
sure sure the effective horizon okay
that's why i mentioned that it's really
important to to remove this mismatch
coefficient yeah for sure i agree
and the natural policy gradient does
that in single agent settings okay
so but but but for for your paper and
and the multi-agent settings
we have this uh obstacle the the
mismatch
cool
all right yeah i guess we could jump
more about that i'm fine
but uh yeah thanks a lot uh so why don't
we thank giannis again
[Applause]
cool so we'll have a quick break now and
then we'll be back at uh 10 15 for drew
food and worst talk
see you guys